- The world wants to know
what it's like to date Terry Crews
and the world needs somebody
to be their romantic icon
and I am that person.
(light music)
Thank you again so much for meeting me
on such short notice.
- Oh yeah, you got it.
I met Keith for the first time today.
He's, you know, a pretty nice guy.
Yeah.
Oh, that's all I need.
I don't want to get tipsy.
- [Waiter] For you?
- I'm gonna have
a little more.
I just hope that he and I hit it off
and we have some things to talk about.
To the most handsome date I've ever had.
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
What's the real Terry like?
- I'm a painter, I'm an artist.
I've designed furniture.
Got a lot of that kind of--
- Terry.
- I enjoy going for new things.
I have a philosophy on life
where the key to success
is doing what you want
and if it's not what you want,
are you really successful?
You got to understand with me
is that I was in the art world
and sports world at the same
time and I saw no difference.
- Really?
- When I got cut from football teams,
I was on six teams in seven years.
When I played in the NFL,
I would go back in the locker
room and ask my teammates
if they wanted portraits painted of them
and that's how I survived.
- There's no reality
where you would paint me?
Let's move on.
- Okay, alright.
- I thought it would be nice if
we share some chocolate.
I don't know if it would be too crazy
if we maybe fed each other.
Why don't you feed me first?
- We had been going at a real nice pace
and then it ramped up to like 100.
I was kinda like whoa.
You're touching the chocolate.
- Obviously, when you have
the body that Terry has,
it comes with a little
bit of machismo, right?
You don't want to show
that just anybody can
feed you a chocolate.
- Just, yeah, I'm gonna
try a piece of that.
- I would love giving this to you.
I would love to take this to you.
- Can I have a bite?
- [Keith] Of course.
- I want to just try it.
- Yeah yeah.
I fed him like a man.
- That's pretty good.
- Yeah.
- Pretty good.
Okay.
- It was something.
You know?
What is next for you?
You have Brooklyn Nine-Nine.
It's doing great.
- It's awesome, man.
- You're an artist, you're
a painter, you're an actor.
What else?
- You know what?
I never thought I'd be an actor ever
but I also am leaving
space for something else.
I don't know what's coming.
One dream I have and this
is no joke, I'm so serious.
I want to farm.
I'm not even kidding.
I want my own--
- What do you want to farm, Terry?
- I'm going to have a farm.
- What kind of plants,
what kind of animals?
- I'm going to have everything.
I mean, the horses, chickens.
- That's irresponsible,
it's hard to raise them all.
You should pick--
- And then I'm gonna have
to hire a bunch of people.
- Yeah, okay, now you're
good, that's it, that'll work.
- You understand what I mean?
- I tell you, if you don't
have shepherding experience--
- I have an app.
No, but I would have an app
so I could watch the farm.
- Yeah like a little watering
that you could water.
- I would make it totally automated.
- Like a cyber farm.
- It'd be a cyber farm, exactly, exactly
because I probably couldn't
be there all the time
but I would have a staff there.
- You're in too much demand.
I'm so lucky to have this time
because I think everybody
kinda wants a piece of you.
- Keith.
You're warming me up here, man.
You know what?
At first, I was like wow.
You know just what to say.
Okay, woo.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
- I have one more little surprise for you.
- Aw.
Thank you, Keith.
- I know that I don't
actually have a firm place
in your family in your future.
- No, no, no, no, no.
You can come home, we can hang out.
It's all good, man.
- Maybe Thanksgiving.
- Maybe not Thanksgiving.
- I can brine the hell out of a turkey.
- No, it would kinda like an off day.
And I just straight out had to say no.
I just had to bust that bubble right away.
It was getting, the bubble
was getting bubblicious.
- To your future, Terry.
- Thank you and to yours, Keith.
That's good, alright, thank you.
Ah, this is really really awesome.
- Could we hug?
- Like a one arm hug?
- Gosh, I'd love a two armed one.
- You know, it's funny 'cause--
- We can keep our
pelvises really far apart.
- Let's just do the one arm.
- That's what I wanted.
That's the kind of hug I wanted.
- Yeah.
- That's what I wanted.
- One and.
- There we go.
Look at that, it feels the same.
Feels the same.
- You smell so good too.
- Thank you.
- You smell so good.
I went into this date
with a little bit of doubt
of where I would fall in Terry's life
and I think he might have
fallen a little bit for me.
- You are a great person.
Would I ever go on
another date with Keith?
If I want to be on Buzzfeed again, yeah.
Yeah, I'd do it.
- Oh, don't forget your flowers.
- Oh no, yeah, that's for the family.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
I'll handle it, I'll handle
it, I'll clean it up.